Speaker 1: So we're right in the middle of
a really interesting confrontation within
the Republican Party. This isn't normal. This
isn't typical. Former President Donald Trump has
endorsed David Perdue in the Republican Georgia
gubernatorial primary. On the other hand, Trump's
own vice president, Mike Pence, has endorsed
Perdue's opponent, Brian Kemp, the incumbent,
in that very same Georgia gubernatorial Republican
primary. Today, tonight, we will hopefully know
the results of that election. It's not looking
good for David Perdue, meaning it's not looking
good for Donald Trump's endorsement.
But the part I want to focus on today,
because we'll have those results tomorrow, is
the increased escalation and tension and attacks
between Donald Trump and Mike Pence, most
of it, by the way, coming from Trump in the
direction of Pence. Yesterday, Donald Trump
appeared on the real America's voice show
Outside the Beltway. It's a
completely unhinged, delusional show,
but a very manic sounding. Trump flipped out
on Mike Pence in this hysterical interview.
Let's take a look at this. And remember, this
is not normal. And Trump seemingly turning on
almost everyone common a move of narcissists.
As soon as people are no longer useful to you
or loyal to you or willing to do whatever you
tell them to do, you turn on them. Take a look.
Speaker 2: Well, I'm very disappointed
in Mike, as a lot of people are. And
he is he just very greatly disappointed me.
He had a great opportunity and all he had
to do was send it back to the legislators.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, Trump continues to
insist that Mike Pence should have and could have
rejected the electoral results on January six,
2021 and say states, each of you decide, each of
you decide who actually won in your state. Now,
unfortunately for Trump, Pence couldn't
do that. There is actually no real
mechanism. The states had already said,
Here are our votes. It's delusional,
but Trump continues to attack Pence for it.
Speaker 2: I have to say, because when you
add all of that ammunition, when you add all of
those things being said about the election and
you had all of the proof that Peter Navarro
and others, many others were talking about,
it would have been very easy to send it back and
have them come back. So I'm very disappointed that
what the stance he took. But that says, you know,
where we're a country. It was very interesting.
They said he had no choice. But in the meantime,
they go and try and change the law. So he's going
to do it. So that means he did have a choice. So
we'll have to see. We'll have to see what it all
happens. But all I know is this our country has
probably never been worse than it is right now.
I think we're in the greatest danger ever of
a nuclear war. I would have never thought that
would have happened. We're in the greatest
danger of a nuclear war where it's just so.
Speaker 1: As you can see, the question was about
the possibility that Mike Pence will run against
Trump and Trump's. He just can't stay focused on
one thing. He's talking about nuclear war. He's
talking about the impossibility of what he wanted
Mike Pence to do. But the important thing is he
essentially at this point has completely turned on
his own former vice president. That's not normal.
Speaker 2: Great danger. We're not a respected
country anymore. So get out there. So important
is a very, very big election that's coming up.
Speaker 1: And by the way, on respected country,
this is not a matter of of my opinion, it's a
matter of global opinion, but it's not a matter
of my opinion. Every serious global study of
America's reputation around the world shows
that since Trump left and Biden came in
respect for the United States has increased
in just about every country, not every
country. I think Russia did prefer Trump,
but just about every country. Trump's just wrong.
Speaker 2: This is going to be big stuff. So David
Perdue, just work hard. David work hard. We're
going to have a big day tomorrow. John Gordon,
also Jody. Hi, Patrick. When you go out, you have
to get out there and vote for every single one,
including Jake Evans. Protect everything. So
good luck to everybody. Yep. Mr. President,
just one last thing. I just want everybody
to know I never said this to you publicly,
but that the worst thing Mike Pence gave
you on January six is not share that fake
legal opinion he had with either you or Pat
Cipollone, the White House legal counsel.
Speaker 1: He this is Peter Navarro, by
the way, Trump's former economic adviser,
a lunatic in his own right.
Speaker 2: Duty to you, sir,
as commander in chief. He had a duty to this
country. He had a duty to the people of America
to show that flawed legal opinion. He did
not do that. Instead, he stuck the knife
not on your back, but in your chest. And for
that, nobody in this country should consider
Mike Pence to be anything other than retired.
Speaker 1: All right. Wow. Guys, this. This is
outrageous. This is this is bizarre. You don't
see stuff like this. And the real question
and my hope is that the answer is yes. Is,
will this rift ultimately work to. Hurt the
Republican voters in the sense of will they stay
home? Will they say, well, I don't know. I mean,
Pence is endorsing this person, but Pence is bad,
according to Trump. But Trump is good according.
Maybe I'll just stay home. I don't know. That's
that's my interest in this is in it being bad
for Republicans. We got one new poll about 2022
yesterday that doesn't look good for Republicans.
Let's see if it continues. And ultimately
we will know what happens in November.